my colleague from the nfl network in the
nfl media group he also uh provided some
high uh some terrific insight on what's
going on in the nfl when he was my guest
for
this past monday night football's
halftime show on westwood one he is my
buddy ian rappaport what's up rap sheet
what's going on what's going on rich you
kind of uh you you kind of made me think
of something that happens to me all the
time which is what um
which is hey man just want to say
you know you do a great job i love
watching you on espn they think you're
shifting ah you're so close
again everything was right until the
last four letters and i know what they
mean
and it's all the same to many people but
i'm like come on man do they think
you're shifter is that what is that what
that means no i'm and i'm i'm seeing i'm
being serious because uh the number of
times i would get you know bob lee i
still get you know hey man i
you know you were great and i'll get
kenny mayne and i'm like i look nothing
like kenny mayne what is your what are
you talking about i get that all the
time um
i would say
one set of every probably
20 times i'll get like
chapter and i'll be like
close same church the same you know same
same synagogue
right right right wrong torah it's right
same synagogue right my problem is
there's no way to correct it without
kind of sounding like a jerk
there's no way to die
so i'm the other guy who you see on tv
yeah an nfl network isn't yet right an
nfl network is an espn you know but it's
it's good to be
hey you're that guy i get that all the
time
you're that guy that guy uh now you're
our guy right now um ian so um how long
is two are gonna be out do you think
with this rib injury
um so he's definitely out this week and
this was an interesting one because on
sunday night and monday everyone was
pretty sure as bruised ribs except he
was in so much pain
that i think they just didn't feel
something was you know felt something
wasn't right so they did more tests and
mri i believe the ct scan too
and that's where you discover you know
like tiny fractures so multiple rib
fractures
uh you know out anywhere from probably
one week to three weeks so like the
actual true week to week so definitely
have this week could be out again the
following week and then you know we'll
see
and obviously you know it's like any
time there's a
texans
uh
you know quarterback question it brings
up deshaun watson obviously the dolphins
were one of the rumored teams as well
right um
and then you know to as uh you know
i wouldn't say on the firmest ground i
don't think anyone is 100 convinced
thousand percent that he's a franchise
quarterback so then brisette comes in
for a game or two it's just it brings up
a lot of questions i would say more
questions than answers well that that
that focuses things on a trade deadline
don't you think i mean uh especially
since this week uh proved that there is
no scenario
uh in which the texans are gonna start
desean watson this year or ask him or
put him in a position to tell his
teammates i am not going to come to the
rescue for you guys
right i mean this week proved it i mean
they just a half an hour ago added jeff
driscoll to the active roster yeah so
what more do you need to know on a short
week
oh 100 and i was even surprised that
people thought there was a chance that
watson could play because you know for
two reasons rich one he has been pretty
clear that he is not going to play for
the texans two
i know this sounds weird but it actually
makes sense for them for him not to play
not risk injury and you know trade him
either when there's more certainty as
far as you know what the team is like
you're trading him to or
at the end of the year when you know
what kind of draft pick you're getting
because
it's two bad scenarios happen if you
trade him
you know right now or you play him one
he could get hurt that ruins your trade
value and also makes him hurt two
you know you'd hate to trade him
somewhere then that team all of a sudden
becomes really good
and then you traded for like the 27th
overall pick you know like that doesn't
help a lot right ian rap report here uh
on the rich eisen show ben
roethlisberger how hurt is he and has he
been hurt because it
the offense just looks so
dreadful in pittsburgh right now i mean
it looked better in the couple of series
that ben had in the preseason against
ones
i mean it's it's looked completely
awful is really the only way to put it
they haven't even gotten naji harris um
uh more than
30 carries so far and two games that
were not even out of hand so
walk me through the steelers ben current
future the whole thing
right now well it does it doesn't seem
like there's a place where somebody said
okay he got injured here on sunday and
so if that's the case
then maybe it is like was this a nagging
injury that we didn't know about was
this kind of just something that was
annoying but he didn't say anything like
it brings up all those things and then
you know like you've done this long
enough usually when something seems off
it usually is off for a reason like if
it looks like
things aren't right in pittsburgh like a
lot of times that means an injury we
don't know about so you know it is
possible
um i think he's probably going to end up
playing only because ben always
literally always plays um but every one
of these little things
you know kind of brings them down just a
little bit i mean he is a gamer and
we've seen this you know i mean i i
we will laugh on game day morning
watching him warm up just limping around
and go out and throw 45 times
but it is a little bit concerning also
he's 38 or something so each of these
little things is not so little
right and he's just right around yeah 39
right pushing 40. and
you know hayden bush
what olualu out for a while now i mean
the defense was at least you could the
defense would got him through uh buffalo
so
what can you tell me about watts
readiness since obviously he's the
defensive player of the year candidate
amongst the many boldface names i just
said
and has looked awesome so far i mean
just awesome um so his injury was
described to me as pretty minor
so i'm not definitely saying he's
playing this week i mean it's a groin
injury so usually you miss some time
but it sounds like if he misses time
it's going to be minimal like maybe one
game or something like that you know
which was which is good news because
he was in street clothes pretty quick on
sunday
so usually when that's the case i was
like oh boy that's not good but it seems
like
this is more minor than anything but
you're right i mean
they are going to have to rely on a lot
of young people very very early and like
it's they have one of the best
infrastructures of any team so i think
they're going to be fine and at least
withstand until reinforcements come back
uh but it is a little bit of a
precarious situation i would say that
well depth is being tested all across
the league right now certainly at the
quarterback position any chatter about
cam newton at all or all teams are like
no we're going to go through our depth
chart we're going to rely on our depth
that was the plan coming in that's the
plan now and then that phone cams phone
would ring when that those plans
somebody's plans
uh to rely on their depth they're going
to get upset that's for sure
so where's cam in all of this best you
can tell no i i i haven't heard him
mention at all well um which
you know we we don't have a situation
where i mean we have one quarterback
that's out for the season but i think
we've seen taylor heineke could actually
be really good so
you know i at least i i think i
understand and people understand why cam
newton wasn't the choice there because
heineken looks
like honestly as good as fitzpatrick or
maybe even better at least at first
blush
um we don't have a situation where you
know kim would come over come in and
take over because
all the guys who are out even tua it's
more one or two games if that um but
again like i haven't heard any i haven't
heard him mention him at all and even
you know each time the patriots signed
him
i don't even think they were competing
with anybody else
so unless i'm missing it which is
possible
i haven't heard any cam newton chatter
at all really well let me give you one
name that uh might might not be uh
talked about very much either because
he's he's out now he's on the covet list
any word on michael thomas on when he
might return
for the saints because they said it
looked like week one hey we don't need
him we too boy do we miss him you know
so you could always use can't guard mike
any word on on on his availability
sometime soon
yeah and that was a that was a really
rough example of you know
dr jekyll james and mr whatever
yes um
uh whatever that is that was i mean
that's the nightmare scenario for the
saints at that weekend and we got you
don't know what jamis you're gonna get
um but
i would say for michael thomas i believe
that he's got a good shot to be out
there week seven and i think if i
remember correctly they have a buy
either week five or six so i think he's
supposed to miss
yep okay okay so then i think he's
supposed to miss five games not six
games
which you know is not ideal but
it's a situation i was thinking the same
thing with bradley chubb yesterday
because you know chubb had ankle surgery
it's so bad to see a great player out
there and not look like himself and last
year michael thomas did not look like
himself just like chubb didn't look like
himself
last week so he had surgery he fixed it
um
i'm sure he is as he tends to be
extremely extremely angry and motivated
in a way that few players can get um so
my guess is when you see michael thomas
you will see a very good version of him
and i will say this yes not being
self-serving at all
but is it possible he's on my fantasy
bench waiting until he comes back i'm
not gonna comment on that but it would
help
well that's part of the reason why i
asked um and so uh what about brandon
ayuk uh we had jimmy g on the show
yesterday and he said
uh the competition is stiff at the
receiver position
so
he's kind of saying the same thing that
the coach is saying which should not
surprise anybody that a quarterback is
echoing what a coach is saying for
whatever reason
but what is going on with one of the top
rookies from last year
coming
back and then being a non-factor and yes
two wins for the team but
one catch
boom that's it what's going on there
for him one catch 15 snaps in the opener
which is not a lot obviously
um
you know i think kyle said it kind of
plainly uh and he sort of tends to do
this just say what he's thinking but
like
i think they need more consistency and
it you know week one felt to me like a
wake-up call
where
just something wasn't right and they
needed more from him and you hope he
responds i mean these are you know these
are human beings right so sometimes
maybe they fall off or maybe they're not
as consistent as they should be or
you know maybe just i'm not saying this
is specifically him but maybe the effort
isn't what which you know what you want
um
it really feels like something better
needs to happen for brandon iac for him
to replicate what was you know what was
the case last year because
it's kind of going the wrong way um and
i you know he's so talented right and
such a unique player that i'm sure he
can turn it around but like you know
there's no
there's no free passes uh and i it's
pretty pretty clear he's not getting one
so i think he needs to
you know kind of pick it up a little bit
and kyle shanahan was pretty plain and
saying so a few minutes left with ian
rap report my colleague from the nfl
media group nfl network at rapsheet on
twitter and also instagram hey um
when you're chit-chatting with everybody
across the league
uh what's the chatter about the taunting
re-emphasis or emphasis right now and
why it's happening and how resolute
those who are demanding it to happen
from ownership and coaching
staffs or coaching
offices how resolute are they
moving forward with this that got fans
are pissed i'll tell you that
so and players aren't happy what are you
hearing on this it is weird though
because like i've seen a lot of the
clips and i think there's you know
people online are definitely mad about
this
and people online tend to get mad about
a lot of things there are some of those
penalties where you know the receiver
gets right in someone's face and we see
it but we can't hear and then the ref
throws a flag and everybody loses their
minds but you're like
we don't know what he said i don't know
i i would say this like it's really
polarizing try that some people come to
me and be like look this is this is bad
the league needs to change this i don't
sense any momentum to change
and i also like there are
a surprising number of people to me
that don't like taunting
and would prefer that it not exist and
are trying to get it out like and i just
know from like a
like a kid perspective you know watching
one little kid taunt another kid in like
a eight-year-old soccer game really
pisses me off no i know um i i'm with
you too it's just it's just the the
officiating of it you're putting the
officials in a position of deciding what
is taunting and what is just excessive
celebration that might be in the
direction of another
you know an opponent you know and then
and then how and then how is it not
taunting a team when you're cartwheeling
in an end zone you know what i'm saying
like but i think you really hit on the
issue there is we
as people who are you know
in the league and
you know report on the league we
celebrate celebrations
yeah like there's i think there's a
weekly award for sobers and i love
celebrations i think it's one of the
best things the league has done in a
long time
and then you're kind of like well isn't
taunting sort of that and you're right
like that's the only thing is trying to
find that fine line i don't think it's
been perfect
but
i would say it seems to be more in the
category now of like something that is a
big issue three or four weeks into the
season then week eight
it won't be an issue anymore because
everyone adapts the officials learn the
players learn and she becomes kind of
like kind of like a thing or tom brady
just got to tweet about it because
that's what that's what
blew up the emphasis on holding a couple
of years ago i mean that's literally
what happened the holding penalties that
came out of preseason like don't worry
it's just the preseason we're just
trying to use the preseason for emphasis
and then the first two and a half two
two weeks plus the thursday night game
was so bad brady tweeted about it poof
was gone
right and now the the emphasis on
taunting it was all these flags in the
the preseason don't worry about it by
the regular season everyone will adjust
and you know i am all for ian having
removed from the game
individual a
does something terrific stands over
defender a and
barks at said defender like that we
don't need you just don't need it but
when guys do something and they go face
to face and they start jawing at each
other
it's it's it's just um a spillover
effect of a very violent game
that that is highly emotional and people
who play it at the highest level are
some of the most emotional people
and and you got to figure out where that
line is and in the meantime it's just
arbitrary it's it's like a
taking targeting and you know and
applying it to celebrating that you're
targeting your your defender with your
celebration
and i i feel like
it's not working so far
and i'm just wondering what you're
hearing on that yeah
and i i just will
i just have not sensed any
i have not sent any move to change and i
really think that the nfl believes
that people will adjust and do much less
taunting at other players and much less
celebrating into the ether
and maybe after week four or week three
or something well this is victory maybe
after week four right it will sort of
adapt to itself i just
i see
i'll say this like i've been surprised i
was reading bill belichick's comments on
this because he seems to be
someone who is a proponent of the anti
uh taunting rule um
there are a surprising number of people
who like the way it is who who would
prefer that taunting was out of the game
i i just i've been surprised by that
part of it saying say that again you're
there are people who like bella again
that's what i'm hearing that there are
the the those in membership ownership
and head coaches you know we had frank
reich on the program and he's just like
hey i i want to
crush everyone just like you know anyone
else like i'm a competitive guy but
tawning should be out and i tell my guys
you know just celebrate in the other
direction and this was after his guy got
called for toning
yeah and i've been surprised how many
people take that stance i just didn't
expect that so that's been that's kind
of the other side of it you know
ian thanks for the time man really
appreciate it we'll chat again look for
my call as always look forward to rich
always great hanging out yeah right back
at you and we'll see you on nfl game day
morning on sunday
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here